all right let's move on from the feudal
system to the communal system because
that's what's happening in San Francisco
with all these startups young people and
people in the tech world they are living
together cooking together working
together it is like a communist bonkers
party let's look at a picture of the
embassy which is in San Francisco that
is where a bunch of tech kids their kids
20s 30s a couple a couple other ones
there they're doing these Co living
spaces let's take a look at the dinner
table at the Embassy look at them just
enjoying a meal that they all cook
together this seems pretty pretty decent
so far right so these are Co living
spaces and they're meant for
entrepreneurs seeking more permanent
home and adopting a lifelong philosophy
of communal living so it's about shared
groceries family values raising the kids
together they have perks like yoga and
things of that nature commune has
actually turned people into douche bag
you you think of you know people may be
searching for some sort of higher level
of communal living and being with your
neighbors I'm not saying that's what
happened I'm saying a lot of it
especially back when they was associated
with like let's do drugs and [ __ ] and
live in economy they've taken all the
sex I was looking for an orgy picture no
word you know some people I know one
person who actually lives in one of the
communes at that 20 mission and I know
some other people they're kind of
involved in a little bit of CO living in
San Francisco because it's expensive and
I'm telling you the amount at San
Francisco supposed to be this wild crazy
town but when you get the tech
entrepreneurs coming in there and what
they want to talk about in the hallways
which it actually says on the website of
some of these things come talk about
branding and get your inner foodie on
air near introverts basically they are
their autistic introverts going I didn't
see any weed there you know it but this
is their bliss their bliss is that and
they are following their bliss in their
own way and I'm actually encouraged by
this because you know out of the 60s out
of that communal living came a lot of
douchebags it became the media
generation
the whole 80s the whole yuppies selfish
selfish the reagan-era is all that stuff
I'm glad to see that a generation is
willing to reconnect with each other
again and live in a space of we the
planet desperately we all need to learn
to do this we've all become selfish and
especially like in LA here we drive
around in our little cocoon cars and you
know and we don't want to deal with
anybody and I'm a person I don't do
groups well I don't do the whole cult
thing you know it's all the new-age
thing but I've been on a lot of Buddhist
retreats and lived in that kind of
setting before and it's lovely it's
really lovely there's something amazing
about being connected to a communal now
there's a lot of [ __ ] that goes on
there and a lot of egos and all that
stuff too but I'm kind of excited by
this okay so I'm glad you took it out of
our joking this story yeah fun of it I
make fun of everything it's like okay
the startup tech community but I love it
too I mean honestly when you have people
especially in tech startups that are
creating technology that kind of further
isolate people and and help people
interact even less yeah to see that
these very people are living by a
different kind of code doubled little
pun there with code that people are
coming together in living and learning
how to share communal space to cook
meals together to depend on each other
to tolerate each other and to share our
ideas actually it's really encouraging
so as much as I made fun of the initial
concept and I think oh gosh we'd want to
do that it's rad it's great and like all
the comedies in the 62 it is slightly
elitist I mean these are you know
education middle class kids you know for
the most part doing this you know
they're not coming together but they are
coming together because of financial
issues they can't I mean
San Francisco is impossible to live by
yourself there's something to what
you're saying though about that it is
middle mostly middle class kids that get
into the tech so it's not you'd think
that maybe lower class they're saying
they're low people with low income are
living together with you know 20 people
on a home out of necessity not because
they wanted to pull their money together
get a ping-pong table and build a
bowling alley but who cares this is what
these people want to do just because
you're middle-class enough money and are
capable of doing this doesn't mean that
you're shipping on people with less
money okay so let me play Bill O'Reilly
for justice
is the most anti-capitalist thing we've
ever heard and it's going to destroy the
nature of the country because these
people are getting together in
innovating in really unique way these
are the people who are going to lead us
in through the 21st century and are
probably going to solve the problems of
the environment and and jobs and all of
that I mean these are the people that
have the minds and the education and the
spare time to think about these things
and when you come together in think I
mean they're there think tanks in some
ways it's an excited it's it's kind of a
think tank from the ground up it's not
you know some Koch brothers think take
you know from from that direction
anti-capitalist because most of the
agenda of the people living there is
entrepreneurship and small business all
these people want to make money they're
saving their money to invest in their
own small businesses to make money so
they can get out and own a mansion 24/7
I think a lot of these people are living
together because they want to bring
common ideas not just for philosophy or
the higher go to the arts it's different
than when we think of like an artist
communing where you have Bill O'Reilly
going it's anti-capitalist instead this
is actually the opposite of this this is
young people wanting to pull their
resources financially emotionally
psychologically intellectually in order
to create more and to make money yeah so
what are these powerhouses by the way um
you can look at it like a yearbook and
you can see who lives there and under it
it says what either tech startup they
work for or what their starting and some
of them instead of their name it says
their name of their company that lives
there yeah capitalist freak whatever
same difference I guess in this case but
so last thought on this is there any
real-world example of this type of thing
working I was trying to think like in
the last hundred years the only thing I
could sort of come up with I guess like
a kibbutz on Israel but even that
they've disappeared because they've
become more capitalist so is there
something about this that they can work
for a little while and then eventually
these people will move on and then the
next crop doesn't quite have the same
belief system I think you're right about
that I I agree you know and I think you
know cult of personality may start a I
mean who knows you know and that kind of
stuff but yeah I think there will be
some watering down of it and some
evolution within this generation but I
think it's an interesting generation
and and maybe all of those playdates and
helicopter parenting added to this maybe
this is like one of the the good kind of
side effects of that kind of parenting
that I always think is ridiculous
extended adolescence in a way when you
have people in their upper 20s and 30s
living in a dorm like culture but it's
not necessarily a negative thing the lot
of time it becomes interesting is when a
company like Facebook or Google or one
of these monsters decides to start
building dorm life things like they are
right now right now Facebook yeah you
can already get your hair cut you can
already do your laundry at Facebook they
already feed you all the meals while
you're there the next step now is to
basically have a company store and
basically have you you know just paying
back into and just only living for the
company instead of mining in a or in a
mine I know your your mind their mining
your intellect Facebook always like the
company store where you go get your
paycheck then just pay the company back
again money like actual company door but
it is what you're saying it's more for
intellectual it's for your time is money
so you're not commuting anymore your
needs are being taking care of your
laundry and your food and all of that
this is coming from the ground up
because they're trying to build the
startup versus what you're saying about
the Koch brothers having a think tank is
coming from the top down in which the
ground up though the more accepted will
be for the larger companies to start
saying hey why don't you come live
together on our you know what a
pepsi-cola compound you know where the
you know bathtubs run free with sugar
water everyone's like okay cool I was
living in a community way right to be
are like uplifting you know futures good
story don't think it's great and
honestly I wish that I had been part of
you know I feel almost like too old to
do something like that now but if I've
been living in San Francisco New York
even here there was a cool co-working
living situation it was appropriate for
me I would do it in a second so yeah I
would there you go